today i think i'll compare portuguese
with a special dialect of portuguese
called spanish
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the langfocus
channel and my name is paul
today's topic is how similar are spanish
and portuguese
as you probably know spanish and
portuguese are both ibero romance
languages that share a common origin
they're different enough that they are
definitely considered different
languages but they're also closely
related and
quite similar in many ways on paper the
two languages look very similar and
speakers of either language can
generally read the other language
without too much trouble
the spoken languages however are more
different from each other and
less mutually intelligible than the
written forms and portuguese speakers
typically understand spoken spanish
better than spanish speakers understand
portuguese
well actually it's mostly because of the
difference in pronunciation between the
two languages but we'll get into that a
little later
spanish and portuguese share about 89
lexical similarity
meaning that 89 of the words have a
cognate or an equivalent in the other
language
now that doesn't always mean that 89 of
the words will be the same
because some of the different words are
very basic and common words
and even though cognate words often look
and sound quite similar there are other
cognates that have developed quite
differently and now
sound and look quite different for
instance this pair of cognates clearly
resemble each other
in spanish mundo and in portuguese
and these words mean earth or world now
here's a less obvious pair of cognates
in spanish beth and in portuguese
these words mean fish so you can see the
connection but it's not quite so obvious
there are some very common everyday
words that are different in the two
languages for example in spanish there's
yopienso from the verb pensar and
yokreo from the verb which both mean
i think these words have cognates in
portuguese but it's also very common to
say
awash from the verb
there is a spanish cognate of this word
ayar but it only means to find
not to think in spanish there's the verb
meaning to look at or to watch in
portuguese
the common verb is there is a portuguese
verb
mirar but it's not commonly used
personal pronouns the personal pronouns
in the two languages are generally
similar but with slightly different
forms for example
but also the formal way of saying you is
normally different
in spanish it's usted in portuguese
there's a word
voce but instead people generally say
us which is like saying sir
or madam these are equivalents of senor
and
senora in spanish but in spanish they're
not used as pronouns
false friends you will constantly
encounter cognates in spanish and
portuguese but you'll also
encounter lots of false friends words
that look and sound the same and might
share a common origin but their meaning
is actually different
and some of these could potentially
cause some crazy misunderstandings
pelado in spanish it means skinned or
peeled but colloquially it also means
someone with a shaved head or a new
haircut
blub in portuguese it has the same basic
meaning of skinned or peeled
but in brazilian portuguese it also
means naked
in portuguese the word for octopus is
bulls
in spanish the word for octopus is pulpo
and
polvo means dust but it also means
something sexual
and kids don't google it in spanish
means a delicious dinner in portuguese
messenger means a weird scene
and senna is also a slang word for thing
so this could mean
a weird thing propina in spanish means
tip like a tip for a waiter
means tuition fees like for university
and in brazilian portuguese it means
bribe
so even though lots of words are pretty
much the same in either language it
might be a little dangerous to assume
that they mean the same thing
pronunciation the main reason that the
spoken forms of the two languages are
less intelligible than the written forms
is because they differ significantly in
phonology
portuguese has much more complex
phonology than spanish with many extra
sounds
and this is one reason that portuguese
speakers have an easier time
understanding spoken spanish than vice
versa
consonants in spanish the b d and g
consonants have
soft pronunciations that occur for
example between vowels
the way those soft sounds work is
different in portuguese
european portuguese has the soft d sound
while some brazilian accents don't
for example in spanish nada in
portuguese
and in brazilian portuguese nada
portuguese doesn't have the soft b in
spanish
saber in portuguese
next the rolled r sound of spanish
corresponds to a rather different sound
in portuguese
when it's at the beginning of a word or
if it's doubled
in spanish rapido in portuguese
in spanish in portuguese
next the sound represented by a double l
in spanish has a corresponding sound in
portuguese represented by
lh for example in spanish there's sayar
and in portuguese there's fellar meaning
fail and portuguese has some consonants
that don't have an equivalent in spanish
first a sound spelled with ch or with x
so in spanish we have yellow but in
portuguese
sega meaning arrives a je sound
in spanish we have agencia and in
portuguese we have
agency this is another example of a
difference in soft consonants
in both languages the letter g
represents a soft g
sound rather than a g when it's followed
by an e or an
i but the soft sound is different in
either language
listen again agency
next sound spanish doesn't really have
a v sound it does have the soft b which
kind of sounds similar to a v
but portuguese has a distinct v sound so
in spanish we have
visited and in portuguese we have
visitor
in spanish we have libro and in
portuguese we have
livre and one more a z
sound the sound z is not found in many
spanish words but in portuguese it's
very common
so in spanish we have brethisso and in
portuguese we have
this sound is often found between vowels
and at the beginning of words
vowels there are quite a few more vowel
sounds in portuguese than there are in
spanish
spanish has five pure vowels while
portuguese has all of those plus
seven additional ones spanish has just
one e
sound which sounds like a portuguese has
this and an additional one like the
e in set in portuguese it's difficult to
predict which one to use in any given
word
these ones are different in spanish mero
in portuguese
but these ones are the same in spanish
mesa
and in portuguese mesa when a word has
the diphthong
e in spanish it usually corresponds to
an open e in portuguese
for example in spanish siete and in
portuguese
set spanish also has just one o
sound like in the word go but shorter
but portuguese has an additional open o
which sounds like the o in pot in
spanish a bill
in portuguese obvi and sometimes the
diphthong
ue in spanish corresponds to the open o
in portuguese so in spanish we have
escuela and in portuguese we have shkola
now this might not seem like major
differences so far but there are lots of
differences like that
reduced vowels vowels in spanish are
quite clearly pronounced in their full
form but vowels in portuguese often
become reduced especially when they are
unstressed at the end of a word so in
spanish we have
casa but in portuguese we have casa
in spanish we have libero and in
portuguese we have
liver in spanish we have avere
which means it opens and in portuguese
we have
up nasal vowels portuguese also has
five nasal vowels that don't occur in
spanish a nasal vowel means that some
air is released through your nose which
creates a distinct sound
vowels become nasalized when they are
followed by a nasal consonant
an m or an n in spanish
and in portuguese kentar in spanish
in sulto and in portuguese
this also happens when there is a tilde
over a vowel like in this portuguese
word
meaning sister because of the extra
vowels in portuguese there are also more
diphthongs
meaning two vowels that blend together
in one syllable this includes some nasal
diphthongs
for example in spanish we have sexion
but in portuguese
it's saxon in spanish we have
limones and in portuguese
little differences like these add up to
make portuguese and spanish sound rather
different
grammar spanish and portuguese grammar
are generally very similar but they do
have numerous differences as well
gender both languages basically have two
genders masculine and feminine
but sometimes the gender of cognate
words is different
for example words in spanish ending with
are masculine and their equivalents in
portuguese ending in
azing are feminine so in spanish we have
el viaje which is masculine but in
portuguese we have
evil which is feminine both languages
have four definite articles for the two
genders in singular and plural
but notice that spanish also has the
neuter singular definite article
it's not used with nouns but with
adjectives or possessive pronouns in
order to use them like nouns
for example which means
the important thing is love in
portuguese it would be
important with o being the masculine
singular definite article
verbs the way verb tenses work in the
two languages is very similar
almost all verb tenses have an exact
equivalent in the other language just
with slightly different conjugations
so in spanish we have
which means we eat fish and in
portuguese that would be
spice so the present tense form is the
same
and next a past tense sentence in
spanish
they ate fish and in portuguese eels
comments
in this case the conjugations aren't
exactly the same but they are equivalent
now a future sentence in spanish
which means i will eat fish and in
portuguese it's
but without any context given for the
simple future tense here this might
sound kind of stiff
and people often use the going to future
form instead
in portuguese it would be
and in spanish it would be yo voya
pescado
one difference in the verb system is
that the perfect tense is formed with a
different auxiliary verb
spanish uses as the auxiliary verb
which means to have but only as an
auxiliary verb
the main verb for to have in spanish is
tener
portuguese has a verb but instead the
verb
tir is used as the auxiliary verb which
means to have
is a cognate of spanish tener
in spanish we have yo eleido libro
which means i have read the book and in
portuguese we have
el tangoli river which means i have been
reading the book
so notice that the auxiliary verbs are
different and notice that the past
participle of the verb meaning
read is almost the same but more
importantly
note that this type of sentence means
something different in either language
in spanish it means i have read the book
in portuguese it means i have been
reading the book
in other words the past action is still
continuing in order to say i have read
the book in portuguese you would use the
preterit tense instead
like this i believe that latin american
spanish is more like portuguese in this
regard
and that difference is only in the
present perfect the past perfect doesn't
have that kind of difference
so if we want to express they had read
the book in spanish we would say
avian leder and in portuguese we would
say
else the main difference between these
two
is just the auxiliary verb word order
the word order is generally quite
similar between the two languages as
you've probably noticed already
but there are some differences too in
yes or no questions
in spanish the subject can come either
before or after the verb
like this
but in portuguese it must come before
the verb like this
alpha english the placement of object
pronouns
in spanish the object pronoun normally
comes before the verb
for example which means he helped me
in portuguese it comes after the verb
like this
another example in spanish
which means are you going to help me or
what and in portuguese
actually the location of the pronoun in
the first sentence is something that
comes from brazilian portuguese but it's
sometimes used in portugal too
because of the influence of brazilian
portuguese through brazilian tv shows
and the like
some people consider the second sentence
to be more proper in european portuguese
contractions with prepositions in
spanish prepositions mostly function as
individual units
with just these exceptions the
preposition the plus the definite
article
becomes meaning from the the preposition
becomes al meaning to the there are just
those two in spanish but in portuguese
prepositions form all sorts of
contractions so in spanish we have
en el libero which means in the book but
in portuguese we have
nou livre in spanish we have de una
senora
which means from a lady but in
portuguese we have
dumas in spanish we have
de aki meaning from here but in
portuguese we have
the ki
these sentences mean portuguese is a
sister language of spanish
in spanish el portugues is
word for word it's the portuguese is
a language sister of the spanish
these sentences consist entirely of
cognates and have identical grammar the
main difference is the different
definite articles
and the words for sister take a somewhat
different form
this pair of words is a good example of
how spanish and portuguese cognates can
sometimes look and sound
quite different let's look at one more
sentence and see what we find
these mean very few countries in the
world take pride in having so many
different styles of music and dance
in spanish muy poco spices
word for word it's very few countries
in the world are proud of having
so many styles different of music and
dance
and then there's the portuguese sentence
word for word very few countries in the
world are proud of having
so many styles different of music
and dance again these sentences are
similar but there are a few differences
the way of expressing very few is
slightly different but the words are
cognates
next notice that in portuguese the
preposition and definite article
contract together into one word while in
spanish there are separate words
next we see the verb corresponding to to
be
in each language estar in spanish and
also
star in portuguese they are both
conjugated in the third person plural
present tense
but you can see that the conjugated
forms are different in either language
next the words here are a bit different
the spanish word is an infinitive form
while the portuguese is a personal
infinitive the infinitive by itself
is and also notice that the word for
dance is different
but also notice that it sounds like the
english word ballet
there's also a cognate word in
portuguese bile
but in portuguese it refers to an event
like a ball or a prom
and in spanish there's also the word
danta which refers to specific types of
artistic dance as opposed to dancing in
general
very often there are possible cognates
for every word in a sentence but they
sometimes have a somewhat different
usage or
frequency of use in either language in
these two similar sentences
we see how similar the two languages can
be with the biggest difference simply
lying in pronunciation but things are
often said more differently
for example a somewhat more natural
sentence in portuguese might be
mint space
stills different in this variation
rather than to be plus an adjective here
we have
can plus the infinitive of a verb
meaning to be proud
so as you can see spanish and portuguese
are indeed sister languages that have a
lot in common
they do have a lot of little differences
that all together make them distinct
languages
but knowing either language would
definitely help you learn the other one
relatively quickly so the question of
the day for speakers of either spanish
or portuguese who have studied the other
language
did you find it easy to learn what was
easy and what was challenging
also feel free to share other examples
of their similarities and differences in
the comments down below
be sure to subscribe to this channel and
also check out langfocus on facebook
twitter and instagram
and a big special thanks to all of my
patreon supporters especially these
magnificent people right here on the
screen
for their monthly pledges thank you for
watching and have a nice
day
[Music]
you